ben first question what advice would you  give to your past self when you're just  entering the recruitment industry  uh listen more ask more questions  and try and hang around with people that  are exceptional at the job  what did you spend your first biggest  commission paycheck on  you'd probably have to ask my wife she  probably spent it for me i'd say  probably our wedding to be honest it all  went into a wedding fund i love that uh  what non-negotiable do you live by each  day that you feel has a massive impact  on your productivity yeah i'm all about  getting [ __ ] done like do what you say  you're gonna do take action and just own  it  last one  uh how do you think we can change the  perception of the recruitment industry  i think everyone um  sharing information is actually really  helping i think it's not a hidden  topic anymore i think people sharing and  collaborating will only help um  increase the  reputation of recruiters  [Music]